welcome back in the last episode kevin
from green mobility told us about
immutable deployments so do immutable
deployments
apply to other components of your system
as well besides cloud run kevin
yeah like we want to prevent drifts
everywhere in our production environment
and for example you can get into trouble
with your current jobs
developers might add all modified jobs
in the cloud scheduler
and after a few weeks you're not sure
what jobs are there and what they're for
ah how do you prevent that drift for
cloud scheduler jobs
let me show you
[Music]
we're using terraform to deploy cloud
scheduler jobs
that way all job definitions are in a
terraform manifest file that's in source
control
it's easy to see when a job was added
and why whenever we apply the terraform
manifest
terraform compares the list of scheduled
jobs in the manifest with the jobs in
production
it then adds or deletes the jobs in
production as needed to make sure the
production contains only the jobs listed
in the manifest
nice that ensures that the production
environment stays consistent
what else are you doing to keep
production under control
we're also focusing on security we
needed to provide transparency and be
strict about
who can see what for example access
groups we have a bi and data
they can run reports we have a devops
group they can deploy code and view
production
and then we have a dev group they can
view production but they can check in
code
but kevin if developers don't have
access to the production environment how
do they know what settings and code
would work there
we have many dev projects delvers are
free to experiment with settings and
test their code in those
projects and every now and then we
destroy the
dev projects and create new ones using
the settings in our production project
wow as you went full serverless is there
anything that worked differently than
you expected
the class scheduler for example wouldn't
start new jobs all ones are running
so our solution to get around that was
just using two cloud schedule jobs
it's actually kind of cool because it
means that the scheduler keeps track of
what is running
which can prevent some really bad bugs
for example if two instances of the same
jobs are trying to modify the database
at the same time
for example you could get into some
really serious trouble
that makes sense also we find that many
of our jobs run at
five minutes past the hour every hour
and that puts a lot of load in our cloud
sql database
we could manually schedule the job start
times over the hour but we have a lot of
conceptual jobs and we keep adding more
it would be nice if cloud scale could
just run our jobs randomly for us
i will let the product manager for cloud
scheduler know
is there anything else you've done to be
more productive with google cloud
some tasks are before often like
switching between projects and uses
requires a lot of clicking and waiting
in the cloud console i wrote two command
line tools
gpc run and gpc of user to quickly
navigate between projects
and users they were easy to write as you
can do so much with the gcloud command
commands from a sales script feel free
to use it nice i will check them out
and i will put the link in the
description below any other learnings
kevin
we also need to sync tens of thousands
of records between our system and an
external system
and this happens a few times per hour at
first we had a system dedicated running
this which was slow and complicated
so what we did was we split this big job
into 500 small jobs using cloud task
which meant we could run them in in
asynchronous lists
in parallel we found that cloud test
made it easy to kick off these 500 just
quickly
and also the code that ran into these
500 small jobs became simpler
500 jobs doesn't that make it harder to
handle errors
it actually makes it easier like each
job is shorter so a few things can go
wrong
and if any of the 500 jobs fails cloud
tasks
tries it again we don't have to write
any of the [ __ ] logic ourselves
oh nice so kevin what's the verdict
does serverless get a thumbs up or a
thumbs down from you
a big thumbs up i could have built the
data ingestion backhands
schedule jobs and so on using virtual
machines but our team has saved so much
time but doing it serverlessly with
firestore cloud run
a bigquery cloud task and also cloud
scheduler
it means that we have been able to add
more functionality to our class
car sharing platform quicker good to
hear kevin
thanks for sharing your serverless
experiences and thank you everyone for
watching
if you have questions for kevin or me
please add them in the comments
also this episode was a little different
from the others in the serverless
expedition series
please let us know if you found it
useful and be sure to like this video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time
[Music]